thank you so much for the great content
the song works
the song really works oh thank you so
much
oh dino appreciate that
okay oh okay let's possibly
um do i play a walrus
and saturn thanks for subbing playing on
walrus
okay so i have a pawn on e4 and may be
expected
let's reinforce the pawn
yeah preventing bishop g5 it's only like
decent square for the bishop
knight d2 is a good move let's take
bishop e7
queen queen d7 queen e2 bishop here
could castle either way oh 95 coming
confusing position
maybe castle kingside then 95 maybe
queen d4 okay let's put the rook on the
open file maybe bishop can come to c5
like coming to g4 potentially i'm also
maybe threatening
some tactics never mind
okay let's attack the queen that
probably only helped white
okay bishop f8
okay
so some knight d5 idea actually knight
d5 followed by bishop b4
is a main idea
yeah this is a secret threat
opponent kind of deals with
oh it's getting spicy i'm going to take
and then play bishop b4 anyway
so i'm stacking the exchange but
probably winning the exchange back
oh the bishop control c3
that's not good
i just lost the exchange the spiciest
thing about you
oh when i order
[Music]
spicy thai food
or just my stafford gambit probably
okay c3 induced ah we're trading rooks
okay i need the song the song will save
me hopefully
okay let's do this i'm down in exchange
not the best position
but we're going to try and fight
let's see five coming oh i have a no a5
doesn't quite work though
how many staffords already today
so many so many okay c5 i take
that's a good move c5 anyway
this move
this is a difficult position my time is
very difficult but i'm threatening
bishop e5
[Music]
this move don't hurt me
don't hurt me
okay night of thrones doesn't work
though
the song's not working i'm getting
smashed
[Music]
no oh okay maybe i'll defend everything
okay let's attack the pawn i have 18
seconds no
[Music]
this is really bad oh
but what's giving me hope giving me lots
of hope
rook is kind of trapped with b7 i take
in c6
c4 coming let's go b5
bominos b4 coming
[Music]
my hope
no
[Music]
don't hurt me
[Music]
[Music]
that was unfortunate